this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you done good morning everyone can
you hear me okay thank you my title says
potato variety diversity attributes and
partners needs in Ethiopia probably most
of you know where eta is Ethiopia is all
the former name Abyssinia that is the
center of diversity of more than 18 16
crops like sorghum tape nope like that
that is the center of diversity of more
than 16 crops in the world but potato is
not endemic teacher bhea it is believed
that it is originated or introduced
about 150 years ago so this green shaded
area is very suitable for potato
production it is estimated about 3
million Hector so probably tripura has
possibly the highest potential of potato
production in sub-saharan Africa so just
the trend also the potato rh expansion
also shows that in 1970s potato
production was 30,000 Hector but in 2014
it was 179,000 Hector it is about
six-fold increment this is because
potato is a very good food security crop
because it is early maturing I yield and
it is good for food in Ethiopia however
however the productivity potato is
decreasing through time nowadays it is
about tent and practice when compared
with 40 tons per hectare when we compare
North American productivity
european potato productivities about 9
10 / octa it is very very small and even
the productivity will be decreased even
parser because of these problems drought
is aggravated through time late blight
especially the main positive business in
ethiopia is devastating and aggravated
through time and depletion of soil
fertility because of soil erosion is
aggravated so this this causes this this
problems also really make potato potato
crop decreasing even further the
Ethiopian agricultural research system
established in especially the potato
program stablished in 1975 and to
increase the productivity of the crop
released 31 new potato varieties with
assumption that local varieties are low
yielding and they have narrow genetic
base and with assumption that these
improved varieties are released for
selected for their yield and late blight
resistance these are the major selection
criteria for the research system and the
other recommendations the research
system did a shift planting seasons to
rainy season because in the in the rain
in the dry season in the dry season the
rainfall status is not is not dependable
for potato gross so the research system
recommend this the dry season production
to main racism production we have four
growing seasons in in Ethiopia the bulk
balamani mehar and muslim baloch bulmer
and machine or dry seasons the this one
is the main rain season
so the research system recommend this
instead of planting rotate on these
seasons planting potatoes and this is
using the main new varieties is a good
strategy based on the research system
but how is the farmers response for this
research recommendations the new
varieties have not been accepted in most
of the farmers as expected what is the
reason behind farmers want to grow local
varieties rather than new varieties
farmers still grow potato in the dry
season done in the new season what is
the reason behind so to see those
problems we propose about for research
objectives the first one is assessment
of local varieties their distribution
and importance in different technologies
the second one identify farmer variety
needs in different area colleges
cropping systems and market access the
served one determined genetic
relationship PQ locality and varieties
with different sources in the world the
first one is measure the relative
tolerance opt up and potato variety to
water stress stress using screeners
experiment so to attain these objectives
we conducted a series of objectives will
come to that that one so the first one
the first research activity it is
published in American Journal potato
research it says positive variety
diversity determinants and implication
potato breeding strategy in Ethiopia we
did a survey we did a survey for six
districts representing different agri
ecologists for example the ligands this
is very dry area and these two are moist
areas these are some humid this are
this area is by it uses bimodal airport
and it is cool Highland this is mid
altitude area and the partners targets
products potato for the market and in
this just in this district new variety
intervention is in high status so the
survey contains semi semi-structured
interviews focus group discussions fill
and storage observations so we recorded
those local varieties and new varieties
new varieties which I mean those
varieties released by the research
system so far so about 14 varieties are
grown in different areas of the country
and the major varieties differed between
districts for example in chambana this a
gather and not java are the main two
varieties and these varieties are widely
marketed in Addis Ababa market in the
northwest these three varieties are
below the Korean simoni are the main one
and in Google and data this variety are
the main one so we have 14 number of
local varieties and in when you come to
the new varieties about six varieties
are recorded and grown but three
varieties are widely grown CSI and good
and end of a letter from sirt1 new
varieties only three varieties that is
nine percent of them are adopted so the
aggregates area locator to new varieties
is qe3 percent when you see the number
of valid is grown per household most of
the farmers grow potato grow more than
one varieties for example somewhere some
most of the farmers in boomer n decatur
grow more than forty forty percent of or
more than that farmers grow three or
more varieties this is for risk
avoidance and for some some
characteristics I'll come through it
with in a minute so each local varieties
how have its own specific
characteristics and in each other I
ecology farmers have varieties for
different purposes farmers have
varieties for drought tolerance farmers
have varieties for adaptation to low
soil fertility especially in remote
areas in remote areas where chemical
fertilizer is not a main main issue a
main source and farmers have late blight
resistance varieties varieties with
storage qualities and farmers have
varieties for market and dazzles we also
recorded potato production practices
practices because this is helpful to
understand the farmers needs so when we
see the those farmers who apply
fertilizer especially in two districts
is the banja they don t is fertilizer at
all and I gained about fifty eight
percent and from even even from those
farmers who use chemical fertilizer most
of the farmers use diammonium phosphate
instead of urea but the research
recommendation is both both die ammonium
phosphate and yer eyes the commended but
most of the farmers want to use only
diammonium phosphate
and most of the farmers do not use them
aside for later black except a shaman in
gamma ray Nikita farmers when we come to
seed source most of the farmers use
their own heat source especially in
Goomer and gate amala ninety percent of
the partners the farms used their own
seat especially in the High Line this
market also have its own sure especially
in the highland areas it is quarried
about 3,100 meter above sea level and
lie kind it's also very cool Highland in
this year as there is no bacterial wilt
reported so far so this in these areas
market share each has its own clay okay
the second the second of my act ii our
activities evolution of genetic
diversity of ethiopian potato germplasm
we collected 44 local varieties with
supporting information that is the the
traitors so far most rates and for how
many years they they they produce these
these varieties so we we collected from
Northwest Ethiopia and thousand Ethiopia
because these two locations represent
more than seventy percent of the potato
area in Ethiopia so we used molecular
characterization and morphological
characterization DNA was isolated from
European Port Authority and local
varieties and sip 31c varieties and we
did this using C dub protocol in in
Ethiopia and clarified using question in
Walter lab and genotype it in 8300 slip
marker using alumina array and sleeps
from 20 to 22 American and 70
european collins also included and from
these markers we used this this amount
of snips in case of morphological
characters we collected those 44
varieties and planted in the screen
house and evaluated about for the flower
characteristic for stream and other
plant characteristic sugar
characteristics to confirm our DNA
structure DNA result is fine so from 44
local varieties about 15 varieties are
unique the rest are duplicates named
duplicates for example Sakura this is
this variety is well known in the
northwest it's also grown in the south
it is it has six names in different
areas it is called Kate energy Lagrange
Merton Mercer in Banja demas inquiry
dimensional a terrible i need mana kind
in / Koji and the wearer so I'm a show
you this this is sakura so this is valid
is widely grown in ethiopia and the
other the other 1a below this also
widely grown and the z's variety about
double it has a very very good fever
ship but the farmers do not want to grow
this variety it is reported that it is
drought tolerant variety but it has a
bitter taste
that is the main program and the natural
white is widely seen in Addis Ababa
market this is so we also grouped
Ethiopian varieties in relation to
European American and super varieties
this is super varieties group we have
three groups within the cluster analysis
this is the seed group this is American
group the black this European group
Ethiopian varieties are found in two
groups in CP groups and European group
especially the oldest varieties like a
below simoni nadroga Rhodri me these are
in the European groups the latest in
local varieties in CP group this makes
sense because 35 years ago ETA PR
introduced potato varieties from
European countries not from sip after
than most of Ethiopian research system
introduced potato varieties from sheep
and probably's these varieties may be
derived from cheap sources the principal
component analysis also showed the same
trend the Ethiopian varieties are
located in the sim and European sources
but the American sources are widely
distributed and is a hetero zygosity
also showed American sources are highly
heterozygous followed by European and if
European sources are better than cheap
sources and when we see the FST taste it
hippin sources it happened clones are
closely related to
sip and European than American so the
search activity it says genetic
variation potato growth and yield
response to water stress during cool and
warm season production Northwest area I
told you we have four seasons and we
were we wanted to taste especially those
those highly drought-affected seasons
bulk and mass now we want to taste
different varieties on these seasons so
we arranged our reports that is the poet
experiment we arranged the pots in 40
applications so each each treatment has
two ports this is a radiated one in the
green red and the red the red port are
the stressed one and we used water
markets and tensiometer Xin storage but
in this tensor meters are not function
well we used water marks water molecules
can monitor monitor the moisture level
the moisture level greater than minus
zero point zero three mega Pascal will
be related less than this one will be
stressed but the the port is the plant
is who rigged ate it uniformly until 40
days and then stressed again for 41 days
like that
so the result shows that this this is
the Sakura is a widely grown variety so
we can use this one at it as a check so
this is a German variety it is reported
to have good drought tolerance so no
variety hour till the disease local this
local check but in warmer season this
varieties really it has a very good
potential when compared with this 111
gram per plant and this variety gave 209
grant program is very good drought
tolerance ability when we see the water
stress susceptibility index in the
National cool season some varieties
balada a new variety a part in a local
variety it is reported to have good
drought tolerance and a bad Ramu I
should I told you previously these are
very good load sub suitability index in
ambala go season this variety new
variety and this a German variety has
very good tolerance to drought and yeah
the loan the number is the better yeah
when you see the granule and the
pictures some in the trust treatment
some tubers have a good marketable size
but not this one as this variety
nutburger oh is very susceptible look
the it reaches 1.5 x ESO value and we
cannot find marketable supersize when
you see the percent and marketable small
size tubers comparing with the check so
quarry this variety about the moon a
local variety this granola this sip
advanced real or because we included
this variety because it it has a good
tolerance to drought and Guerra and a
new variety released for
drought-stricken areas has a very good a
high number of low number of small
tippers in both Messina and Burke when
we see the army analysis that is the
same trend this granola a bad damu this
has it they fit well to the warm season
condition to Balak season and the this
the regime china sequeira is good for
the snow or cool season when you see the
correlation matrix anyway those were
those traits in relation to yield market
a virtue variant and total to variant
those stem with above-ground biomass and
leaf area ratio has have a negative
relationship with yield but harvest
index has a positive relationship with
marketable and total Jabbar unit
then this is my last presentation man
last activity identification of armor
priorities in potato products through
parts part of our isolation this is
accepted for publication and we used PBS
approach the previous approach uses
first situation analysis search for
varieties and experimentation this one
is related to experimentation hood
because we we we did situation analysis
in our survey and we did search for
varieties in our second experiment that
is evolution genetic evaluation trans
because of this this study is intended
to find out really the local varieties
are low yielding we need to test that
and we need to test that why the
partners do not want to grow in the dry
season and the research recommendation
in the weight season why not we need to
check that and we need to find out what
are the farmers and variety needs so we
used two districts in the highlanders
with different degree college one is dry
in the other weight and we used diverse
set of varieties from local and from new
varieties and we organized farmers
research groups we organized Varmus
research groups each group has 40
certina 39 members each each group has
sown chair and secretary and they
evaluated the varieties in the flowering
stage in the harvesting stage and after
three months after storage this is like
an area this is ill man area so we
grouped based on gender probably we
wanted to see the gender issues here so
we we recorded those but 23 one treats
to to collect these 23 trades first we
asked farmers which are the best five
varieties and what is the reason behind
and we also asked them what are the bad
performing varieties what is the reason
behind so these all these traitors are
recorded from those reasons and we
record those reasons and we the partners
evaluated those those those traits again
so we have mail ratings here we're
familiar things in each in each location
so from here high yield long shelf life
because long shelf-life varieties are
very important especially these are very
determining trades for variety
acceptance in each API the research
system didn't want to see this this one
they simply see the yield and a little
blind but the farmers really consider
this is a very important trait and
suitable for sequential are wasting the
farmers want to use one to harvest two
times at least in the one firm in one
growing season drought tolerance
low-salt soil fertility adaptation
especially in ligand the males are males
are very they have a very good concern
in soil fertility adaptation late blight
resistance suitability to boiling
suitability to sue steel that is for
source
these are the main the main domain
trades and are also another another
place market demand especially in in
mana tolerance to wind and hail damage
fixed aims these are very very important
traits so so we tested in the in the
field we tested the yield of local
varieties and new varieties so it's
really Ethiopian local varieties are
longer than the new varieties we can see
the Java byte is about 24 ton character
but here in the in the new varieties we
cannot get uniform so the new varieties
are not low yielding and in case of
seasons because we will taste the two
seasons at the right season that
Isabella mark and the main rain season
so those late maturing varieties fit
well to the velimir season because this
barracks needs long maturation time
Ballmer season is a long much muttering
period the short early maturing
varieties our feet well to the mercies
endure the main rain season so it is
impossible to recommend those late
maturing varieties to grow in the manor
in season so our conclusion in case of
potato genetic research resource
assessment we record the European major
varieties privacy's maybe the first
report their distribution meritus in
ethiopia number of ballots grown per
household and reasons documented genetic
variation among each other varieties and
our outside clones are documented our
study also negative the belief that a
tape and varieties have neurogenetic
piece
so if your pian varieties does not have
a narrow genetic base based on our study
the yield response of selected local
products under water stress is
documented this finding also negates the
believes I type and level collaborators
are low yielding they are not loading
probably because if you can we started
with this tester seat probably those
those seeds probably infected that may
be the reason for low yield but in our
study it will be a local varieties some
of the violets at least they're good
good as new varieties in case of
production systems four seasons recorded
we named one season because there was a
confusion we call it velimir season so
there is a confusion this velimir season
some people say it is mad some people
say that is called balik but it is
ambition so we we call it belmar season
differences in growing season between
potato growing server regions where
documented major potato production
challenges and their importance are
recorded in case of farmers variety
needs we give answers why liberation or
are not accepted as expected now where
we have answers about that primal farmer
cited 23 traits are important key
variety traits differ among our ecology
calzones cropping systems and market
rates for example Northwest needs
another variety especially Northwest
needs long story varieties South farmers
need quick dormancy varieties so there
is a difference in demand of varieties
so we have recommendations these
recommendations that is it is the
it is good to register the main tube and
Ethiopian local varieties and prepare
and eat you can put it or color catalog
with some pictures utilize the major
available major varieties for future
building multiplied visa status testers
starter seed of major far more varieties
incorporates additional quality and
stress tolerance rate during variety
development and address the violation in
a gray ecology cropping systems market
access during variety development so we
have an occluded an acknowledgement asst
international programs office through
kaha programs because without this
program I would not be here so I tank
international programs balrog Lee psi D
Richard brought in the world Christian
Church in Audi Center international
petite center if you can biotechnology
research institute and this personals
thank you rly thank you so much indeed
questions sly
one question that I hadn't thought of
before which was you found it only a
small number of the varieties you looked
at were genetically distinct there's 14
out of from 44 for pound fifteen million
but when you design your water stress
experiment you didn't know that that
that that information came later so were
the varieties that you chose for the
water stress experiment today were they
all in week varieties that were not the
same yeah I sure all of my body's in the
waters Poisson unit during one at first
we included some but we remove later
because we move another two instruments
what is so meaty pretty subtle you
remove some because you found out that
they were so yeah because I remember we
included two varieties that is unlucky
me and after the molecular
characterization this virus have the
same and we won
so as you continue to vote move on with
future breeding programs what kind of
trans leave prior an eclipse on our your
first straits that you decided
it's very good very good question
because in internet access system
because I am utterly and when you have
focused on the end and let life but I
understand now not right now these two
are not only that the truth rates are
not only this true story is the mint
because the virus want to store four
elements for food so for example about
why I'm always ready known by the
pharmacy lobby because it is it can
escape to use in the soil that's very
unique variety so storage is the main
one storage tray and some other traits
like travel to us
this is based on the ongoing college
conditions market or so so its own body
for example where you go in sha sha na
na this totally fit yet if you want to
introduce today the skin body go and use
that one nor no one wants to go registry
my ready because it is depending on the
the market to market to market 97 one
uses five the scale bar X so the harvest
drugs I accept those legs kill my ex
lifetime so what is also in social
storage payment is cloud and get like
absorbs a major
which of your results do you think will
surprise the Ethiopian research
community the most
the the first one is genetic the genetic
diversity analysis because in so many
photos I have seen that for examples of
body so Cory reported six times as soon
as new by different lines so most of the
44 local varieties are considered as
identical piles so our our bracelet
shows that most of them are in case this
is a very good very good i sensing and
the other thing is that local bars are
not alone in our results shows that
local bars are not really and even if
you can localize have some some
diversity within within the country
these are the release two important
messages that
i watch out without eyes have a
follow-up question when you begin your
research did you think the local
varieties were low yielding and you
think there were so many different local
varieties there are only a few but
there's a lot of duplication local
varieties when you begin your research
having been Ethiopian contain a
researcher for a long time were you
expecting this was this a surprise to
you too yeah even even even those high
in variety or loca- alex m very few but
since they have a good athletes but you
have not gave these activities of these
traits from new bodies for example the
trace will get from a body still who
cannot gain we don't get these trails
from lubar I any kind of all right if I
don't and we we have also some bodies in
the eastern part of Italy I hope so
especially that Traum tolerance they
make some important product but I didn't
taste them because I have no time to
resign from the near future I am going
to do that and i am going to correlate
those car varieties in the eastern if
you
das and even we we have we have some
something local varieties in the
centrality and some lights are not
included in the latest analysis because
we didn't taste within we found some
after game analysis so I believe some
very important local policies are very
good for closing purpose but that is
more but it can be starting
great to see that
women barbers in here
wonder if you could help me understand
how much decision power they have
termini varieties actually get plenty
especially in one location the partners
tournament at the demons are responsible
for selecting tubers and that are very
good in identifying by despair estates
and for example in a treat sequential
harvesting trade this is a very
important trait for women done with the
wind rated g street hi that me because
and then that does have concern for the
food for the supply in the like idea so
the high-power track safe and they can
lead but we cannot totally say humans
are can't decide but in some in some
farmers and some farmer some women
partners are also independent observer
husband so they can they can decide
which by a candle so mighty fine art
remember sequential art sequential are
bursting for example in one growing
season the moving zone means zoning goes
further to the field especially in
development season in August in the
august season during around maturation
but not fully much they go to the field
and harvests Angeles and covers the
suena game but they they drooped
disturbs the rules and this is stolen
they they took some bigger tours and
covers the swinging and after tweakers
after two weeks they go back again and
harvest some chores if you guys like
that situation are harvesting that is a
very good trait for women parties
because it is a good means it means for
food security become in August you
cannot find in from harvest data that's
why what it is a very very good khlo
because if mattress in august june july
august is a very serious manses for
solid food for this evening
and his Harvard anchoring in monsey is
called hungry with this segment so what
you do is only called harvested between
that man so that's why we say but it is
a good call see ya what can be done
about why verson see when we visited we
saw feels for you know how to be kept
like 75 percentage of all disease
before I included our bodies to our
research activities we tasted the
varieties for these 46 viruses and one
battery and more than eighty percent of
our collection is inflicted by biased
that's very sad so for example for one
variety Agatha we found some tangibles
113 because we collected from different
sources so only what you were we thought
only want you so we multiply the screen
out in vitro and Miss canals to get up
get a motor tours so this is it is
really very very challenging part and
even the study even if we use clean seas
we can increase if you're a positive
program by 50 person so most of Egypt
and farms are rated by buyers and
mr. government's trying to start up was
a seat multiplication problems oops
reduce the virus phone
there are some seats production schemes
especially energy especially from
netherlands and as a call cause i
usually concentrate on New Balance North
local minds and we have to tissue
cultures facilities in Ethiopia what is
it polenta is about 27 this reservoir is
a bargain and they are working to
multiply from if more than 40,000
minotaurs per year and they focus on new
buyers don't log online but after after
my my work in the national potato Center
particular from international consider
Center took some sugars minute words
from my collection to multiply is
probably that week
future but our capacities very limited
that's why farmers use only their own
seems every time probably turning years
or something is that usually use their
own seed so that that's one of the
causes for food or a filter
and the other question through some
minor
thank you very much too much thank you
your schedule for the common my views on
the airplane is 6am this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu